so the title of the talk apparently
little bit misleading in the sense that
this is what was planned for me to
present but myself and my students we
only go to access to Mathematica online
yesterday so there was no in-class
experience yet with Mathematica online
although I use Mathematica all the time
and i would i would rather talk more
about where i am as a teacher and where
i would like to be and the main question
i would like to address is how
Mathematica online can possibly help me
to move in the direction where I want to
be and maybe Mathematica online can help
me define where I want to be but over
and over over the past years I thought
about different pieces of the course and
of the kitchen arrangements and they
thought well what do it why don't I just
replace this with Mathematica whether
they use Mathematica instead and there
are all kinds of challenges with that
proposition and and I will try to
describe the challenges and overall kind
of situation around the use of
Mathematica and mathematic online in
particular so the there are basic
building blocks as I consider the static
parts of the course so there is a course
management system well of course the
natural thing to have in class and we
currently use blackboard and I use it to
the very minimum I just pulled the class
roster and it allows me to authenticate
students and check if they are in my
class or not and by using four basic
class announcements so
it's the video very very minimal usage
the reason for that is that I believe
it's of very low quality and I mean the
software is a very low quality and the
expectation is very low and the system
is basically enforced by university but
basically that's the only place where I
can pull the roster the list of the
students so I have to use it it has to
be on my list the homework tests I put
them together because I believe in the
need for consistency in the course
whatever I want students to be able to
do on the tests I would like them to
practice during the homework and they
don't believe in the idea that oh you do
those homework problems from the
textbook but then on the test i will
give you some innovative for problems to
work on so that's the reason for them to
be together and and again i use online
homework delivery system i currently use
webassign it does a pretty good job of
having the problems delivered randomized
for each student so that each problem is
as it uses different numbers but under
the same template and different students
get different versions of the same
problem and it works for both homeworks
and the tests the numerical answers are
graded automatically so it takes off
load from me about grading dancers the
gradebook is there it works fine I have
well I can set it up the way I wanted
and one of the most important things the
all the technical issues are resolved by
that system by webassign any problem
student experiences with the system
student doesn't contact me contact
webassign there is of it I am not
involved in that process at all so
that's a great benefit
in my view in comparison to anything
homegrown I have a colleague in my
department who does a system on his own
machine and company has a complicated
setup of delivering homework problems so
any question about student running a
laptop running ubuntu operating system
right at two a.m. in the morning five
minutes before the deadline and
submitting the file through the slow
connection well things happen right and
I don't want to deal with those things
so that that's why I'm using one of the
homework delivery systems it is about
testing basic skills I don't consider
this system being the kind of the goal
in this sense of assessment most of the
grade in the class comes from what I
grade and what I believe the student
understands or not from the explanations
and not from final answer but students
still like getting some positive rate
nonzero great for the right answer and
I'm willing to do that and to give them
that opportunity and that makes them
happy that makes me happy so that's fine
and and for engineers and most of my
siblings are engineers it is important
to get the right answer so so it this
system has a good place in the class and
I think it it is it values about less
than twenty percent of the grade all
together over the course and I don't
mind that now the next thing is the
videos i eventually recorded the
lectures life lectures of myself and
then decided to replace the lectures
with those videos so that in class we do
some more problem-solving activities so
that students solve problems and I hope
them doing that and that's how the class
organized but but then I need a space to
store videos can that be Wolfram cloud I
don't think so for for this moment right
so maybe eventually but youtube is a
perfect place so I use YouTube and every
student knows what it is and an
important thing that they just realized
this morning is that I've never heard
any complaint from student about YouTube
they do complain about the homework
online system about my website about
university website being slow being
cranky being this and that I know
YouTube can be slow I mean I experienced
that I'd never heard from students so
that tells you about about their
believes their expectations and the
tolerance to two different systems right
so there YouTube is a good place
everybody is okay with having videos
there and having my lectures on the
YouTube great so so i use it at the
mathematica files well of course not
everything can be said and not
everything should be said something
should be written and like formulas and
stuff so I prepared those i call them
lecture notes but basically those are
materials I wanted to present the
students some computations some simple
solution some affiliations and over time
it becomes a large collection of files
hundreds of files are the questions are
where should I store them so that the
students have simple access to the files
how to organize all these files and
there are of course the standard way to
organize is according to the time right
the time of the course goes on and you
organize it linearly but then at the end
I would like them to see connections
between different topics i would like to
learn to see how
chapter one is connected to chapter
seven right and it becomes the
organization more complex than just
linear it because basically a graph
right that I would like eventually for
them to understand how all things are
connected and i hope the software can
support this kind of presentation
presentation as a complex system not
just a linear sequence of chapter 1
chapter 2 i currently organize all that
stuff on the google website and it plays
well with the necessity to to have for
those videos and the notebook files
organized around the same thing so
basically Google ends up being currently
the place for me to organize all the
course materials although a challenge is
to connect that to the homework system
because the homework system is closed
right I cannot give a link from my
google website to the homework and they
I can give a link from the homework to
google website but the homework system
is usually so close that everything
needs to be done there by hand and so
it's very tedious and I just don't have
time to do that so this this connection
is 0 is a challenge now the another
bunch of mathematical files are
basically you can think of them as
streaming over time during the semester
those are the files where students work
they do the homework in the files they
do the quizzes in the class they do the
tests in those mathematical files they
submit them to me and I'm getting those
in bunches like 30 files at a time 60
files at the time the same questions
where the way store and most importantly
how do I communicate with the student
about that about that file the challenge
here is that I currently use Google
Drive I could have used dropbox or
something else but the challenge is that
any insisting like that treats
Mathematica as the foreign system and
therefore it's as probably good as
sending by email back and forth but once
you begin sending by email it's a lot of
even sharing on Google Drive it's a lot
of things to to organize and well it it
is it is not obvious but alright I
probably have to tell you that it is
quite a challenge to make the class of
students named file in certain way all
right never happens right it doesn't
matter how I explain it I explain name
your file your last name underscore your
first name what do I get as a result
most of them yes they do it the right
way some of them asked can you tell me
again can you show me example yes I can
i right if I give that for me broadsky
underscore Nikolai and guess what one or
two students will name their foil
broadsky underscore nicole i right so
I'm just giving this example to
illustrate the difficulty of delegation
to the students it doesn't work I mean
you are saving some time but afterwards
you are spending more time fixing things
and searching for things because they
share file video which starts with test
and it just literally test not just one
not test two not last name not first
name just test right how do you find it
I have zillions of those tests over the
years
I mean its own google i can google it
and they get those lists and lists and
so so I I wish I can master this art of
dedication but it just doesn't work with
the students and the Lost static piece
is the forum this is really the piece
that students appreciate they like it
they use it probably doesn't really
matter where that forum is I use Google
just because a lot of services that i
use our google based and since i use
google drive students have to have
google account so Google forum is group
is good but again that's can can I do
that in math America Online probably not
probably not at this time right so what
I'm saying is that there are pieces that
I hope I can do much better with
mathematica online but there are lots of
pieces that cannot be done at this point
and I will have to leave for several
years with all these pieces present now
what it means is that for students they
do have to learn all these pieces and
there will be one extra piece
mathematica online so mathematic online
for them comes as piece number six in
the long list of where to go they have
to go to course management system to get
this they have to go to homework online
system to do the homework and then they
watch me you're here they read files
there they submit files into the
different place so it is pretty
complicated right and and at some point
at some point some of the students get
overwhelmed and and they forget and they
just don't do it on the first time and
so that those are the challenges and
that's why I just don't want to pad or
rather I would like to be very careful
about what to add and
and what to try and so that was the
basically the static part of all the
pieces now let me talk about the
dynamics what actually happens in the
class and i would like to separate out
of class this column of three things
that happen only out of class three
course management system Elaine never
asked them to do anything with that all
announcements are out of class the
videos of course they don't watch videos
in class and the forum is solely for out
of class communication so those three
pieces are naturally only out of class
the both pieces are things that I
normally use both out of class and in
class and those involve the homework
quizzes tests that happen in class and
at home files can be viewed and I would
like them sometimes to refer to these
files in class and the of course the
files they work out during class should
be submitted during class as well as at
home so the only in class pieces are
going to be a file sharing open file
sharing happens out of class also but
what I'm talking here is kind of
real-time file sharing when when we
decide that we are done with this topic
so let's have a quiz and how do i do the
crease well I I want them to work in
those files and what I would like to
have is ability to automatically create
a file so suppose I have a template of a
file we decrease I would like that file
to be copied for as many times as number
of students i have and shared with those
students and i would like that work to
be done
automatically so that's I think what
Matt American wine should be able to do
and I'm looking forward to automate that
process now the collaboration is in his
interesting piece and they I was quite
surprised how useful it was in the usual
classroom although I ran it in computer
lab because I want students to work on
with Mathematica during the class I
always thought well if I am really in
the class and all the students are here
and they have 30 of them so it's not
like a big crowd why do I need online
collaboration during the class well I do
need it because in order to check what
goes on with all the students I have to
run all right I have to walk around and
I have to zoom into what they're doing
and they have to understand where they
are and decide whether the student needs
some help or not and then go to the next
one it takes a lot of time whatever time
it takes to look at one screen x 30 and
that's just the time to look at or not
to not even to start helping so I found
it very beneficial to just check
everything on my teachers computer so at
the time as I was working with Google
Documents so i would share 30 documents
i will open all the 30 documents on my
screen and they will click click click
click click and 30 clicks can be done in
very short time in comparison to running
around and looking so and then then
another piece I found useful was yes
having that individual sharing and
watching what every student is doing but
then having one file share it with
everybody and I would look at typical
challenges students are having I would
copy paste their piece of work from
their individual file to the common foil
and bring it up to the glass and
discussion in very uh nonnamous way
right I'm bringing this piece and I'm
asking everybody well what do you all
think right can-can what should we do in
this situation and and everybody's on
pretty much the same page but it's well
it's very it's very different from the
situation when I just write something on
the board and ask everybody and well
there are many little outfits for was
for why I like it I just like it and and
another another aspect of of the same
story is it when a quiche online right
online course is a totally different
direction in many respects but in law in
class kind of during class we do the
video conferencing and now google allows
to have video conferencing with up to 10
students so it worked perfectly for my
graduate class right now and it
currently allows to stream and record
the session directly to youtube so that
all i need to do is click record button
at the beginning click stop button at
the end and all three hours of this one
of of the class are there and there is
nothing i have to do about video editing
conversion uploading everything is done
automatically so that's great and that's
Google right so so again it's just
another piece where I don't expect ball
from cloud to be well to be dealing with
video conferencing and video streaming
but that means that google will be
present in my system so it will be nice
to have it is some
or some integration some some
relationship between warfarin cloud and
Google or at the minimum the possibility
of embedding videos into mathematica
files in the cloud and so that that's
that's basically where I am why I see I
have one minute left and I would just
wrap it up with it's basically a
question that would be happy to discuss
where can I improve the whole thing what
can I replace with Mathematica what can
I do better going forward right because
now you have a much better picture of
where I am and and I would appreciate
any comments and if I just can't stand
not mentioning that story the class I
thought last week started with again
that video conferencing and google
hangout that i started and started
recording and then a student is late and
then apparently the student is not
joining the handguard is not Jenny the
class but the student is typing
something in the chat to everybody and
we are all kind of not clear why is it
draining was it that student is not
joining apparently when the student goes
to google account and sees the
invitation to the hang out there are two
buttons when i record the Hangout one
button is to join and another button is
to play the recording because the
recording is immediately available so
the student instead of clicking the join
clicked the recording and started
playing and the student was always two
or three minutes behind what was going
on so his submissions were always like
two three minutes behind and then at
some point the student was curious so
why is it that he is asking questions
and nobody reacts to it and the teacher
is so ignorant
right so well thank you